- [Voiceover] In 1954,
Steve and Gayle Henson
bought a ranch in California
called Sweetwater Ranch.
The area they loved,
the name not so much.
So they changed it to Hidden Valley Ranch.
I think you can guess where this is going.
Ranch dressing is called ranch dressing
because it was made on a ranch.
So here's the story, it's a quickie.
Steve was working in Alaska, he had a crew
and for lunch he would whip up
this buttermilk dressing for
them, which they all loved.
Cut to 1954, we're back
at Hidden Valley Ranch,
Gayle and Steve have opened
their ranch up to guests
and at the end of the day,
everyone would sit around
and Steve would serve his ranch dressing.
Okay, here was the original recipe.
Buttermilk, mayo, sour
cream, dried parsley,
dried onion, dried
garlic, salt and pepper.
And people were all like, oh my God
I love your ranch dressing.
So Steve and Gayle started selling it.
It began as mail order for 75 cents
they would send a pack of the
flavoring and it took off.
In 1973, Clorox came in and
bought it for the big bucks,
eight million of them
and they began selling it
as Hidden Valley Ranch Dressing.
Move up into the 90's
and ranch is being named
the most popular dressing in America.
And there it is, ranch
dressing, it came from a ranch.
What do you know?